son nom harbour nombre de rues et
d'écoles et pourtant cette figure
emblématique de l'aviation française et
peut célébrer aujourd'hui 68 ans après
sa mort aujourd'hui on se penche sur la
carrière incroyable de maryse bastié
pionnière française de l'aviation
[Musique]
enfant la petite marie louise veut être
marin âgé de 6 ans elle rêve de
découverte d' aventure est d'explorer
les grands espaces elle a l'esprit
contemplatif et ne comprend pas encore
tout à fait pourquoi ce monde
d'exploration n'est ouvert qu'aux
garçons
je ne savais pas alors qu'une femme peut
réaliser des rêves d'homme quand elle
veut s'en donner la peine mais elle rêve
maryse elle rêve encore chaque dimanche
son père l'emmène dans une grande
promenade dans sa ville natale de
limoges dans les insouciante premières
années du 20ème siècle
son père lavoie déjà devenir médecin
mais l'esprit curieux de maryse n'en
démord pas elle est ventre les jouets
pour en découvrir les mécanismes et son
foyer familial lui offre une enfance
heureuse jusqu'à ce que son père ne
contractent la tuberculose la longue
maladie suivie de son décès donne un
coup de massue moral et financier à la
famille désormais installé dans un
minuscule appartement
maryse devient une dure à cuire dans les
faubourgs de limoges elle n'hésite pas à
défendre les enfants maltraités par
d'autres et remporte très souvent les
combats la mort de son père l'a endurci
et maryse n'a pas perdu son goût de
l'aventuré
au contraire il se renforce
les années passent maryse obtient un
travail dans une fabrique de chaussures
elle déteste ce travail mais sa
conscience professionnelle la pousse à y
mettre du soin ma vie de garçon dehors
libre ardente batailleuse ne brisait le
corps et l'esprit et je n'éprouvais pas
le besoin de me réfugier dans la lecture
le rêve suffisait tam et évasion à
partir du jour où j'entrais à l'atelier
je découvris le monde merveilleux que la
lecture ouvre à l'âme prisonnière tout
mais soupe a certes acheté des bouquins
j'avais hâte de rentrer chez moi pour
les dévorer roman d aventures de voyages
roman tout court j'achetais tout je
lisais tout j'avais enfin trouvé la
porte magique qui permettait à la
captive que j'étais de s'évader déjà
hors de la vie quotidienne dans de
folles envolées et ce fut la guerre la
guerre qui allait apporter à mon
adolescence en formation un élément de
gravité et de sérieux des chaussures
elle passe à la couture de blues médical
particulièrement et durant les années de
la guerre elle est mariée de force à 17
ans et à son premier enfant
germa c'est aussi durant ces années que
son frère âgé de 20 ans mort au combat
dans l'enfer de verdun
la fin de la guerre marque le début
d'une bien meilleure période pour maryse
elle divorce en 1920 pour rejoindre un
aviateur vétéran de la grande guerre
louis bastié et leur amour est à la
mesure de leurs envies d'aventuré il
avait tout de suite représentait pour
moi toute la poésie et toute la bravoure
de cette époque exceptionnelle où se
déployèrent tant de vertus héroïques
ignoré depuis balayée par les années
troubles et âpre qui suivirent une belle
figure énergique des yeux clairs qui
semblait toujours chercher dans le ciel
quelques routes plus large plus aéré un
sourire de vainqueur tel il m'était
apparu j'imagine que les jeunes filles
romanesque se représente ainsi le
chevalier de la légende un chevalier et
sa princesse désormais marié qui rêve d'
aventure qui sont pour le moment trop
occupé à essayer de vivre de leur
boutique de chaussures à cognac en
charente mais en 1925
louis est affecté à l'école d'aviation
militaire de mérignac en tant
qu'instructeur de vol le couple déménage
sur un terrain militaire et maryse a
bien l'intention elle aussi d'apprendre
à piloter
j'accompagnais mon mari sur le terrain
je montais en passagère chaque fois que
je le pouvais je surveillais le vol des
lâchers et je savais tenir le volant
avant même de l'avoir eu en main à cette
époque l'aviation féminine n'était guère
encombré certes il est vêtu de belz
aviatrice aux temps héroïques de
l'aviation thérèse pelletier qui était
déjà en 1908 élèves de de la grange
la baronne de la roche hélène du trieux
marie marvingt jane eyre veine marthe
richard mademoiselle pallier tout
excellent pilote
mais durant la période qui avait suivi
immédiatement la guerre les femmes ne se
passionnait pas beaucoup pour l'aviation
moi je rêvais d'obtenir mon brevet
[Musique]
louis ne peut pas lui donner des cours
de pilotage car il est rattaché à
l'école militaire
mais guy bart instructeur civile décide
de la prendre sous son aile et lui faire
passer son brevet l'instructeur comme
l'élève sont deux fortes personnalités
mais les deux poursuivre l'objectif de
faire de maryse bastié une aviatrice
lors de son premier lâcher son premier
vol seul dans l'avion elle décolle fait
un circuit parfait et se pose
délicatement guy bart fier de son élève
cours vers elle mais peu contente de son
atterrissage
elle croit que guy vient pour lui passer
un savon pour éviter le savons elle
remet les gaz et s'enfuit réalisant un
nouveau circuit parfait après quelques
autres épreuves réussi haut la main ça y
est désormais maryse adl désormais je
pouvait voler de mes propres ailes
je n'avais jamais mieux mesurer toute
l'ivresse qui tenait dans cette phrase
si banal pour d'autres je ne peux
exprimer toute la joie profonde et
grisante qui a contenu cette inoubliable
minutes où pour la première fois je me
trouvait seul à bord et où je tenais les
commandes allégresse d'avoir triomphé de
voir aboutir ses efforts orgueil aussi
de se prouver à soi même et aux autres
qu'on n'avait pas eu tort de vouloir
mais avoir son brevet ne veut pas dire
qu'elle peut voler quand bon lui semble
maryse n'a pas d'avion et pas les moyens
d'en acheter un c'est alors que guy
bartz lui propose un défi aérien qui
amènerait sur elle les projecteurs et
donc les moyens de poursuivre ses
ambitions passer sous le pont
transbordeur de bordeaux dont la
construction a été abandonnée depuis la
guerre en 1925 il consiste en deux
grands pylônes de près de cent mètres et
des câbles se balançant jusqu'à une
dizaine de mètres au minimum au dessus
de la garonne à bord du code ronger 3 de
gebhart elle s'élance le 6 octobre 1925
huit jours à peine après l'obtention de
son brevet de pilote et réussi l'exploit
devant des journalistes et badauds
subjugué mais malgré cette grande
victoire
maryse n'obtient aucune récompense au
delà de son quart d'heure de gloire
médiatique elle fait quelques vols à
paris mais cherche toujours à pouvoir
partir à l'aventuré
son mari lui continue son travail
d'instructeurs à mérignac
jusqu'au 15 octobre 1926 un accident
d'avion terrible petite phrase mon
minuscule est tragique dans leur
quotidienne simplicité auxquelles on ne
pense jamais lorsqu'on a adopté une fois
pour toutes ce métier terrible et divin
qui consiste à se battre avec les
éléments insoumis souvent autant je ne
voulais pas encore et même après j'avais
tremblé pour mon pilote
lorsqu'un retard me semblait suspect ou
anormales et puis sa confiance avait
fini par me gagner j'ai cru voir devant
moi se fermer l'horizon tandis que pour
la première fois je regardais le ciel
d'un an et demi pourtant je me suis
reprise et l'énergie mais revenu la
crasse qui m'en lisait l'âme s'est
dissipé en même temps que se lever en
moi comme un soleil dans un ciel
déblayer l'éclatante vérité rien ne
meurt qui portent des ailes non les
ailes blessés ne meurt pas tout entière
tant qu'il ait d'autres elle pour
reprendre et continuer leur essor
victorieux vers l'espace femmes fortes
maryse bastié n'abandonne pas l'aviation
pour autant
désormais elle volera aussi pour lui
[Musique]
bordeaux pour de bon et part s'installer
à paris cloués au sol elles rêvent
d'avoir une nouvelle occasion de voler
elle passe le plus clair de son temps
libre à contempler les avions s'élancer
du terrain d'orly en attendant
patiemment son tour
il vient finalement en 1927 quand
monsieur caudron industriels de
l'aéronautique lui offre sa chance de
réaliser des baptêmes de l'air qui elle
l'espère lui permettront un jour
d'acheter l'avion avec quelle ivresse je
retrouvais sous le ventre refuse l'aide
ma machine tous ces plans largement
étendu ses chemins aérien élastique et
doux que plus de deux années de
contraintes rampante au sol n'avait pu
me faire d apprendre avec quelle joie
profonde et sensible je maniais le
manche à balai je touchais les manettes
je suivais les vivantes oscillations de
l'aiguillé sur mes instruments en bas
c'est la terre géométriques et moucheté
de jaune de vert de brun avec ses carré
et triangle c'est losange ses clochers
pareils à des jouets d'enfants
le ruban étroit et brillant du fleuve
les voix de fer aux sentiments rapide
les autos qui se traîne comme des
cloportes de ses auteurs ou me
transporte mon beau coursier tous
égalise tout s'harmonise château ou
chaumières belles villas ou pauvre
maison temple ou chapelles rustique se
présente sur un plan unique et les liens
poudreux des routes qui les unissent
semble les envelopper dans un réseau de
fraternelle amour ici la grande voix
discordante de la terre faite de rires
et de cris de son de trompe d'appel de
sirènes de bruit cloche de sifflements
et de règlement ne déchire pas
l'atmosphère où seuls rythmé et
harmoniser comme une sourde prière de
des votes sous une voûte d'église le
champ unis et murmurant du moteur berce
le silence infinie
c'est un an plus tard accompagné du
pilote droit qu'elle gagne la seconde
place du rallye de reims dont la
récompense lui permet d'acheter son
avion en 1928 toujours encore avec droit
il bat le record du monde de distance en
ligne droite pour un avion biplace léger
avec 1058 km parcourus entre paris et
chebbi a tout fait dans l'actuelle
pologne
mais lors de ces deux prouesses elle est
passagère ce n'est pas suffisant elle
veut accomplir de grandes choses
seul en 1929 elle se lance dans le
record de durée de vol féminin sans
cesse repoussée à l'époque par les
aviatrices américaine le 21 juin elle se
pose après 24 heures de vol soit deux
heures de moins que le record américain
le caudron préparés spécialement pour
elle n'avait pas la capacité de pétrole
pour battre le record après des
modifications elle retente son coup le
28 juillet dans une météo infernale elle
se pose après 26 heures et 48 minutes
soit 26 minutes de plus que les
américaines
ça y est elle à son premier record du
monde en solitaire
le temps était elle à l'aube du 29
juillet qu'aucun avion ligne de pris le
départ
c'est assez dire à quel point les
preuves avaient été pénible mais je
venais de prouver que si avec des
conditions atmosphériques détestables
j'avais pu enlever le record à
l'américaine je pouvais faire encore
bien mieux avec des conditions
atmosphériques meilleur
son prochain objectif c'est le record
tous sexes confondus de distance en
ligne droite d'un avion léger en
solitaire et du même coup le record de
distance féminin mais aucun avion
français ne seraient capables de
réaliser un tel vol elle vise
l'acquisition d'un clem allemand mais
dans l'intervalle l'ena bernstein lui
prend son record de durée de vol elle
décide alors de le reprendre mais va
échouer quatre fois à cause de problèmes
mécaniques ou de météo la cinquième
tentative est la bonne mais ce n'est pas
de tout repos
elle s'élance du terrain du bourget
alors que la france entière attend
l'arrivée imminente de costes et
bellonte à new york son vol à elle est
donc peu médiatisé vers 10 heures en
passant au-dessus du bourget je vis
jaillir une flamme
c'était le message de mes amis qui
m'annonçait que les deux
transatlantiques avaient touché new york
j'ai poussé un hourra de satisfaction
tandis que je sentais une rafale
d'entousiasme balayer les incertitudes
les dieux étaient avec nous pour
célébrer cet exploit ne pouvant
autrement extérioriser mon allégresse
jeux mis à chanter puis à siffler à
tue-tête rivalisant de bruit avec mon
moteur que j'arrivais à dominer dans les
notes aiguës geste est installé aux
premières loges au lever de l'aurore qui
ce matin là se donnait pour moi ce fut
une revue à grand spectacle que les plus
beaux music hall du monde ne pourront
jamais monté de façon aussi somptueuse
et prenante
cela commença par une bande grisaille
vers l'orient la grisaille
s'éclaircissent argent tu as tu un tas
de rose de mauvais d'or et bientôt
autour de moi le ciel s'embrasa le jeune
soleil apparu ardent et triomphal et je
l'applaudis comme il se doit une aussi
brillante vedette en bas la terre
s'éveille et la vie recommence
moi je continue elle trouve le temps
long à tourner au dessus de l'aérodrome
attendant que les heures passent tandis
que les vapeurs d'échappement emplissent
ses poumons que le froid de la nuit
s'installe et qu'il faut encore passer
une seconde nuit en l'air elle doit
lutter contre la douleur de ses crampes
et surtout contre le sommeil qui serait
signé son arrêt de mort
un nouveau regard sur ma montre après
tant d'autres ça y est j'ai battu le
record de durée jeu pour atterrir mais
il y à de l'essence dans les réservoirs
je peux tenir donc je dois tenir cela
m'apparaît avec une indiscutable
évidence
elle finit par se poser après 37 heures
et 55 minutes de vol le visage tuméfié
et enflé et sa main droite pleines dents
poule mais le record est battu les
records en fait record du monde féminin
de durée record du monde de durée dans
un avion léger et même record du monde
pour un pilote seul aux commandes
ayant reconquis son record elle peut
désormais se remettre sur le projet
qu'elle avait abandonnée quelques mois
plus tôt celui du record de distance en
ligne droite pour préparer le vol elle
peut compter sur dieudonné costes
navigateur hors pair il lui suggère un
vol de paris à kazan en russie
elle part du bourget à bord de son clem
accompagné de guy bart à bord d'un
caudron 232 qui finit par la laisser
continuer après avoir passé liège malgré
l'avion qui tient difficilement la ligne
droite elle prend le temps d'observer le
paysage qui défile sous zèle le rhin les
forêts allemande puis moscou nijni
novgorod
puis le carburant la force à se poser
près de youri no le record était de 2006
160 km elle voulait en parcourir 3000 et
au final elle en aura parcouru 2976 en
30 heures et 30 minutes
une fois au sol elle a toutes les peines
du monde à se faire comprendre et à
empêcher les badauds de prendre des
souvenirs de son avion car il doit
encore pouvoir faire le chemin inverse
heureusement elle peut le faire par
étapes nini puis moscou et königsberg où
elle est retenue plusieurs jours à cause
de défauts dans la paperasse et enfin
cologne puis paris ce n'est que le 21
juillet que je quittais colonnes lui
porte paris où j'arrive à 15h reçu par
le capitaine esteban représentant du
ministre de l'air et une foule d'amis
avec une vive émotion je retrouvais
enfin l'aérodrome et lorsque je sortir
la carlingue je foulais dampier joyeux
cette terre du bourget qui représentait
pour moi à 7 minutes toute la terre de
france
la france à qui j'étais fier après 6000
km de voyage de rapporter deux records
du monde
suite à ce nouvel exploit
maryse bastié obtient non seulement la
légion d'honneur mais surtout le harmon
trophy récompense aéronautique
internationale quelle est la première
française mais pas la dernière à
remporter malgré tout ça sa carrière
retombe dans l'oubli général il en va
ainsi de la gloire éphémère et
capricieuse elle vous effleure de son
aile fulgurante et s'envolent aussitôt
vers d'autres sujets qu'elle éclaire de
son fugitif rayonnement pour les rejeter
dans l'ombre avec la même rapidité
qu'elle a mis à les en sortir
cette fois encore le problème de la vie
quotidienne l'incertitude du lendemain
se présentait avec une terrible
actualité c'est une longue traversée du
désert qui attend un nouveau maryse elle
est cantonnée à faire des présentations
d'avion potez sur les salons travail
qu'elle exècre
à cette occasion elle peut tout de même
se rendre en afrique du nord et visité
l'algérie le maroc et la tunisie par
deux fois durant cette période également
son fils germain née de sa première
union
17 de la fièvre typhoïde puis elle aussi
tombe malade et le médecin du bourget
lui retire sa licence pour raisons
médicales
il fallut bien se rendre à l'évidence je
crachais 1 mais pistons comme nous
disons de façon imagée je partis à la
montagne le piston ce remis d'aplomb et
lorsque le docteur eu dûment constaté
que j'avais repris 2 kg il me restitue à
ma licence
dans ces heures pénibles je pu mesurer
parfois avec un brin d'amertume certains
vilains côté de l'âme humaine
au lieu de m'encourager ont cherché à
enfoncer la méchanceté la jalousie les
mesquineries caractère se donnèrent
libre cours autour de moi on s'apitoie
ya avec une satisfaction à peine
déguisée
maryse se dégonflait maryse était fichu
fini on ne la reverrais jamais sur le
terrain je serrais les dents et
j'attendais mon heure puis il y avait
tout de même pour me consoler de ses
affligeante petitesse les chics types
les vrais amis tous ceux qui me
connaissant bien ne me retirais pas leur
confiance et ceci me consoler de cela
après des remaniements chez potez maryse
bastié perd son emploi elle fonde alors
à orly une école d'aviation avec son
moniteur guy bart
elle se plaît de continuer à voler mais
a encore ce goût de l'aventuré vise un
nouvel exploit la traversée de
l'atlantique sud
ce vol avait déjà été accompli par joe
hahn batten une pilote australienne mais
bastié compte bien être plus rapide mais
d'abord elle va réaliser un vol d'essai
c'est alors que je partis en décembre 35
de dakar pour natal avec mermoz en
m'accueillant à son bord mermoz me dit
vous serez mon petit le troisième pilote
je passais noël à natal le premier jour
de l'an 1936 nous étions de retour à
dakar
mais ces 6000 kilomètres au dessus du
lot ne m'avait pas découragé au
contraire j'étais encore plus décidé
qu'au départ à poursuivre la réalisation
de nos projets elle va devoir se battre
avec le ministère de l'air pour obtenir
là
on caudron simone qu'on lui promet cela
prendra des mois au prix de nombreux
efforts de paperasse de négociation et
d'insistance elle finit par l'acquérir à
aider marc les vols d'essai elle se rend
en afrique avec l'avion aidés par les
personnels au sol d'air france puis
après un court retour à paris elle
rejoint dakar point de départ la
traversée mais avant de partir elle doit
être sûr que tout est favorable au
dessus de l'atlantique
elle doit attendre l'arrivée de com est
un pilote chevronné qui fait la
traversée inverse et doit lui donner le
go ou pas une fois qu'il arrivera à
dakar il y avait 23 jours que la houle
funèbre de l'atlantique s'était refermé
sur la croix du sud et sur ses occupants
les épouses des disparus était la
désespérée accroché peut-être un vague
espoir mais craintif pour moi et elle me
conjurait de ne pas partir comme est
arrive et donne son go il faut y aller
maintenant
après quelques heures de repos le
navigateur l'endroit lui trace sa route
et la voilà partie dans la brume du
matin direction natale le vol est calme
sans aucun problème mécanique et elle
gère au mieux sa navigation
elle avait annoncé qu'elle le ferait en
12 heures et elle arrive au sud natal
après une traversée de 12h05 la suite du
périple
c'est désormais rio puis pelo tasse et
enfin buenos aires jeu baptisé mon avion
le jean mermoz une grande amie de
l'aviation mademoiselle suzanne deutsch
de la meurthe qui a tant fait pour les
ailes françaises et qui m'honore de son
amitié me l'avait déjà suggéré avant le
départ à ce moment là j'avais hésité à
le faire ni mon avion ni mois alors nous
n'étions digne d'un si beau non il
fallait vaincre pour le mériter à natal
nous avions vaincu et m'était possible
d'attacher à notre victoire le nom du
grand pilote qui m'avaient soutenu dans
mes projets et kim avait honoré de sa
confiance
de plus le nom de jean mermoz vis-à-vis
des populations brésilienne est entourée
d'un immense prestige
il faut voir avec quelle respect avec
quelle ferveur il est prononcé
puis vient le trajet retour elle voulait
à la base aller jusqu'à santiago du
chili
mais on lui offre une place en passagers
depuis buenos aires via la ligne
transatlantique reçu en héroïne à dakar
puis paris elle est bardé de récompenses
et de médailles
elle crée une école d'aviation maryse
bastié aviation et s'engage ensuite en
faveur du droit de vote des femmes mais
aussi leur droit de servir dans l'armée
en tant que combattante
son combat ne paiera pas puisque lorsque
la seconde guerre mondiale éclate elle
se retrouve pilote de convoyage pour la
croix rouge
elle utilise cette position pour glaner
des informations sur les forces
allemandes
mais lors d'un de ces convoyage un
soldat allemand la bouscule et lui brise
le coude droit elle gardera des
séquelles ne pourra plus jamais piloté
elle rejoint ensuite les forces
françaises libres et intègres
après la guerre le premier corps
militaire de pilotes féminins initiative
qu'elle avait tant espéré voir se créer
mais ce corps ne sera actif que deux ans
elle intègre en 1951 le centre d'essais
en vol de brétigny dans les relations
publiques et dans le cadre de ses
fonctions elle assiste à un meeting
aérien
le 6 juillet 1952 ici à l'aérodrome de
lyon bron
la grande fête bat son plein en présence
de milliers de spectateurs et d'invités
de marque et le clou du spectacle c'est
la présentation du nord atlas un
prototype d'avion largueur de
parachutistes aux commandes le
commandant pénix accompagné du
mécanicien navigant alberti soeur du
radio albert grise ainsi que trois
techniciens de la société nationale de
construction aéronautique du nord la
firme produisant le prototype
contre toute attente maryse bastié
embarque avec eux sous les
applaudissements de la foule
l'avion sa ligne d'école effet le
premier circuit autour de l'aérodrome
puis le pilote engage un passage bat
avec un moteur volontairement coupé pour
montrer les capacités de l'avion à
fonctionner dans ces conditions il
engage ensuite une chandelle c'est à
dire un virage à 180 degrés tout en
prenant de l'altitude
l'avion part alors en décrochage et
tombe à pic
il s'écrase au sol et prend feu les sept
membres d'équipage dont maryse bastié
périssent
c'est donc près d'ici qui lie à bientôt
70 ans une grande figure de l'aviation
française partait en passagère d'un vol
ou un pilote a fait une erreur
aujourd'hui même si l'aéroport de bron a
énormément changé que l'aérogare a été
détruit et que l'aviation commerciale
quitter la plateforme pour s'installer
sur l'aéroport saint-exupéry la stèle en
mémoire de l'équipage du nord atlas est
toujours présente
bien qu'elle a été de nombreuses fois
déplacé à cause de toutes les
restructurations de l'aéroport
la piste d'où elle s'est élancée pour la
dernière fois n'est plus qu'un terrain
vague et les grands gars qui ont
accueilli les grands avions caravelle ne
sont plus que des entrepôts de stockage
de castorama à bordeaux le transbordeur
de son premier record a été détruit par
les allemands sous l'occupation
et il n'en reste presque aucune trace
quant à maryse bastié après avoir reçu
tous les honneurs et hommages de la
nation
elle repose au cimetière montparnasse à
paris sous une stèle qui honore sa
passion de l'aviation
maryse bastié à l'instar des marie
marvingt jacqueline auriol hélène
boucher et tant d'autres ce sera a battu
toute sa vie pour réaliser ses rêves
entouré par la mort de ses proches dès
son plus jeune âge d'abord de son père
puis de l'amour de sa vie de son fils de
ses amis aviateurs et aviatrice elle
aura bravé la mort dans des vols qui
repoussait les limites et finalement
partira en vol lors d'une démonstration
alors qu elle était passagère une
disparition loin d'être à la hauteur de
sa légende
comment aujourd'hui ne pas sentir en moi
s'exalter mais fort c'est ma volonté
s'affirmer mon désir de rester dignes de
la confiance dont m'honore grandir mon
espoir d'aller toujours plus loin
toujours plus haut
sur cette route que jalonnent temps de
pierre noircie lourde à notre coeur car
pour nous pilotes ils se mêlent sans
cesse à nos triomphes l'ombre d'une
tristesse notre victoire porte toujours
à son front blanc une sombre cocarde
au cours de ces pages où je viens
d'évoquer ma vie j'ai salué au passage
tant de camarades qui aujourd'hui manque
à l'appel
drouhin belle guilbaud goulette
l'alouette le mois maurice weiss maillet
bat jacques savary carlier tous et
toutes
léna et vous hélène une des plus purs
figures dont s'enorgueillissent notre
aviation et vous mermoz la plus grande
et tant d'autres plus obscurs mais non
moins héroïque s'ajoute à ce funèbre
palmarès je n'ai qu'à fermer les yeux
pour évoquer vos beaux visages qui ont
tous entre les bords du casque de cuir
la même sérénité confiante la même calme
force le même regard glas flammes une
fois pour toutes si fixée et c'est à
vous que je demande à la veille de
partir à nouveau vers mon destin de
protéger mais elles afin que je puisse
continuer à servir la cause de
l'aviation française comme vous l'avez
servi par vos actions et par votre
exemple jusqu'au dernier souffle
[Musique]
j'espère que
sur maryse bastié une grande figure de
l'aviation on n'en parlera pas mal
d'autres figures féminines de l'aviation
cette année parce que il ya beaucoup à
dire
en fait on a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
à dire en général sur sur l'aviation
donc c'est pas les sujets qui manquent
dans tous les cas si vous avez aimé
comme d'habitude vous pouvez laisser un
like commentait vous abonner à l'est sur
la boutique alors je vais ajouter des
nouveaux trucs sur la boutique en 2020
donc n'hésitez pas à aller y faire un
tour et dans tous les cas je vous dis
bonne année et la semaine prochaine pour
un nouvel épisode de stardust ciao